all right guys
bang bang i have a very very special
treat for you today
robert is here thank you so much for
doing this sir welcome my pleasure
all right so for those that don't know
you are uh
uh the brain behind dunkin donuts and
the absolute
epic scale that uh that that business
ultimately achieved
maybe we could talk a little bit about
just your background before dunkin
donuts and kind of where you grew up and
how did you eventually uh come to uh to
run the business
it's a family business i sort of
figuratively grew up over the store
worked in all kinds of jobs as a kid
running donut shops running canteen
carts
my dad had a lot of different businesses
so i
i spent time putting in my hours in each
of them
and then went into hotel school i came
back
worked a bit for the business i went to
the army did my military service and
those years was
mandatory military service and then
after that went to
graduate school and uh i graduated uh
business school in 1963 and lo and
behold at that time my father
turned to me and what i can only
describe as a breathtaking moment
uh asked me if i wouldn't take over the
ceo ship of his business then called
universal food systems which are eight
little businesses
and as you can imagine uh a little bit
cocky 25 year old fresh with an mba but
still an
overwhelming request something i didn't
expect
i thought i'd be joining the family
business i went to hotel school
and so i was studying to go into the
business but clearly not in that
capacity
and so when you take over as the ceo uh
i love how you describe being the 25
year old with an mba
and kind of uh you know let's go take on
the world uh
talk a little bit about what was the
aspiration did you know that you wanted
to build kind of national chain
um and really kind of scale the business
or was that something that just kind of
naturally happened
like when you took over ceo what was the
goal the real goal was
to try to keep the family business in
the family
my dad was eighth grade educated guy he
always wanted to be a millionaire after
taxes
he had a partner his brother-in-law who
he split that partnership they didn't
get along um
the partner my uncle started a
competitive donut chain with the money
that he took from
the sale of his half of the business and
so
um my real goal at the time really was
to try to straighten out the business to
beat our competitor
to family rivals in the donut business
and i thought i saw a way
to straighten out what was a chaotic
business situation
when i arrived in 63. my profits had
stagnated my dad was trying to sell the
business
couldn't sell it uh he wanted a million
and a half dollars to be a millionaire
after taxes
and he had really left the day-to-day
management of the business to an
executive vice president
a former montgomery ward executive
and um basically i thought that i could
do a better job
in terms of rationalizing the business
putting it on the right track
than my predecessor who was this fellow
who was running the business on a
day-to-day basis
so my aspirations really were to please
my dad
keep the family business from being sold
and try to grow it but
in terms of a big grand design plan
35 years later that evolved
as the journey progressed but
but i but i did think i saw a way to
straighten out the chaos that i
inherited
got it and so uh you served as the
dunkin donuts ceo
for uh 35 years um talk a little bit
just
today as you you know look back and
reflect
uh it has become one of the the largest
most nationally scaled
uh chains what are some of the lessons
learned or takeaways that you had
from that 35-year journey right there's
so many stories in there there's so many
different things that you probably
remember but what are the big kind of
takeaways
uh if you had to summarize it in my book
really it's a buffet
of lessons stories and experiences
and that can apply to almost anyone not
only in business but people just
designing a life
so it depends upon where an individual
might be my own personal experience
is that when i read a book attend a
seminar
even have conversations with colleagues
which were really my big
teaching moments encountering a problem
i often found that i come away with
maybe two three possible nuggets
and almost always were those things that
i was wrestling with at the moment that
i
began to search for an answer by
attending the seminar or reading the
book
and so much and so is true in the case
of a book that i read so
for example if you're an emerging
entrepreneur i think
the lessons about the opportunities that
exist within the franchise system
i think can be illuminating uh the
importance of perseverance second
chances
i think are critical if you're if you're
joining a family business the unique
opportunities and challenges that are
inherent
that may be helpful if you're trying to
scale a mid-sizer
or an emerging business larger the
issues about planning
that we found useful how we basically
recruited retained motivated uh a really
well i consider to be a phenomenal staff
great teammates
might be useful um if you're a larger
company
how we emerged and found ways of being
able to organize our board of directors
i think was kind of unique and very
useful
to me as the ceo and you might find
benefit there so
i can't pin one or two key lessons
out of all of it i i think i lead with
the notion that
um the leadership is essential whether
it's a family whether it's a company
whether it's a country
if the leadership is faulty if the
character the leader is wanting
then almost all that follows will will
be a problem
and the only way to change is you can't
change it sort of from the middle
you can't change it from the bottom the
only way you can really change it
is if the leader changes and so that's a
critical lesson
and the the functions of what a ceo does
for critical functions that i found that
i had to focus on like
hope will be useful to others and add
value to other other executives
absolutely so uh you wrote this book um
the title is around the corner to around
the world a dozen lessons of
uh i learned running dunkin donuts and
and it literally is packed with
all kinds of different things um i think
one of the pieces that is so
interesting to me personally is uh not
only did you scale
uh what was a family business into this
large national chain
but you also were consistently tapped
for
your experience and knowledge so you sat
on the boards of domino's and sonic and
kind of these other types of businesses
and as you think back how much of
what you were learning as an operator uh
at
dunkin donuts gave you the ability to
kind of be a good board member be a good
sounding board and governor
of those other businesses right were
there a lot of kind of
um common lessons and common uh
challenges and obstacles that each of
these businesses were going through
uh or did you find that even though they
were kind of in the food services
space these other businesses actually
had different challenges and different
things that they dealt with than
what you were dealing with that's the
operator seat at duncan
well 35 years is a long run and it gave
me an opportunity to
make a lot of mistakes and
so those setbacks and successes i think
were helpful
as i served on other boards and
basically i
was a believer that i you know stick
stuck to my knitting
the things i knew so i only served on
boards or either
of uh chain operators small box
retailers i call them they either
utilize franchise
as a method of distribution and it could
have been in the automotive industry
or or it could have been in the food
service industry and
and i did find uh that on
on a board that there is a an advantage
to having
an operator alongside other types
people who understand governance people
who understand maybe international
marketing what other issues that
business may be facing i think comprise
an effective award
but having a practitioner someone who's
been there done that's been helpful and
the answer to your question is yes
i found my experiences were
extraordinarily helpful
for example i was on one board where we
owned a
cotton a muffler repair and non-muffled
repair but the transmission repair
business
and we bought amco well i had experience
in buying my competitor mr donut and
rebadging them to duncan
so that kind of experience could be very
very useful
to to us as cotman as we bought amco and
merged the two brands together
and began to rebadge the stores under
one brand so there were lots and lots of
experiences
that i think i brought from one business
even to the automotive
aftermarket repair business that were
useful
absolutely and so obviously a lot of
what you've kind of learned
and i think built your career on uh was
finding the best people right and kind
of just whether it was uh
other board members uh executives
franchisees
just people people people when you
thought about people how much of this
was trying to find kind of
talent that was uh impressive but did
not yet
have kind of years and years of
experience doing something and so they
could kind of grow into the role
versus you wanted to go find people who
had already done the job let's say at
another company or on a bigger scale
like were you hiring for uh experience
or were you
more focused on hiring for kind of
potential and uh
competency there were three things that
i
utilized really the company utilized
the first was a real crisp
understanding of the assignment we
wanted someone to fill
and the better you define the assignment
the more likely you are to find a
candidate to come fulfill that
assignment
so i spent a lot of time thinking about
what is it
exactly where are we what do we need
filled in that job
so it's a definition of a job the second
uh philosophy or principle that we sort
of followed was
that we weren't looking for someone who
was
uh effective or knowledgeable in all
things we really really
we were a team culture we relied on
the complementarity of the skills in the
team
and it was no big including myself
no big admission not to be good at
everything certain things
we were thrown to be better at and not
so good at others
and the whole notion was to have in the
team the complementarity of skills
that we really would support and lift
each other up so long as you had mutual
respect
no backbiting which was not allowed in
our culture we
basically wouldn't put up with that and
the third thing was fit
and you had to fit the culture and the
culture in our case was
you know a teamwork aspirations yet
we were we were we liked to win uh
winning was a part of us i dna
so whenever we sort of achieve one
objective we set more lofty objectives
to
to spur us forward we we kept changing
all the time and kept growing
so i would say those were the three sort
of principles
that we utilize in some cases uh it
didn't require a lot of prior knowledge
and
in fact just the fit and the
complementarity of
the personalities might have been enough
depending on the assignment
yeah it's really interesting how um
you obviously did this for so long you
know exactly what you were looking for
and i think that that's a key
piece to this is uh if you just go out
and say hey we want to hire somebody you
obviously can make all kinds of mistakes
but when you say we specifically want to
hire somebody based on these three
criteria
that focus seems to drastically increase
the probability that you do it the right
way right
i agree absolutely right yeah today's
environment
um in both the public and private
markets uh could be described as a
frothy if i was to be kind um and
there's all kinds of uh
kind of craziness and and people are
kind of scratching their head as to
what's going on
you've got experience with public and
private companies
how do you think about you know when a
private company should go public when
they should stay private when they
should stay family owned first take on
investors like
just how do you think about navigating
what i'll call the capital markets and
kind of governance of public and private
companies is there some framework that
you would use
to uh to think through that if you were
an executive today
both have pros and cons i i'm ambivalent
about the answer to that
i i think having a public company
is a great tool with stock options to be
able to attract and retain
and be able to punch above your weight
if you've got a growth company
that's a huge advantage uh by the same
token
uh when their quarterly earnings
can be a terrible um tight noose around
your neck
and and uh when you really have to make
some longer-term investments and weight
in an environment that historically had
been maximized shareholder return and
with
lots of opportunity as the
private equity buyout funds that are
looking for act or activist shareholders
that are looking for that opportunity
can step in so you have the issue of
control
so on the one hand there are tremendous
advantages of public ownership in my
view
and by the same token there are some
disadvantages uh
if i were to do it again if i could have
and i had to sell the business in order
to
equitize my father's uh holdings and and
uh and not have the company sold uh
we didn't need a lot of capital uh i
would have
invented phantom stock options to
replicate those of a public company and
i would have stayed private
yeah and it's really interesting i think
today too when
um the equation almost changes or the
evaluation
uh when the public markets will just
be so disjointed it seems like from kind
of traditional multiples and things like
that
it's almost as if the financial
incentive becomes greater
to for people to get into the public
market but i recently had a gentleman on
he's been the
ceo of a company for uh it's publicly
traded for 22 years
and what he said to me was once you're
in the public markets
it's really hard to go back you can go
back but you're pretty much a public
company and so you have to understand
it's not just about the short-term
decision-making
you know you're completely changing the
way that you're going to govern this
business and kind of make decisions
uh and do you want to sign up for that
or not
in my case and i broke the 35 years into
six distinct eras
the first five years we were magical we
made
little mistakes we moved from from
success to success
the second five years once we're a
publicly owned company
that success became a terrible
impediment
to future success we were growing the
first five years at 50
compounded i basically changed the
mission and objectives now as a public
company
to try to maintain that frothy price we
were trading at 60 70 times earnings
we were back in the late 60s akin
most food service franchising businesses
were akin to
what you see in high-tech businesses
today in terms of the darling of wall
street
lost my way changed the mission
and tried to maintain an unrealistic
objective
in terms of mentoring maintaining share
price and
almost drove the company off a cliff
that's when i learned the importance of
strategy
and how important it is if you're aiming
at the wrong target
the kind of cataclysmic result that that
can create
and how is the leader you can take a
whole team and franchisees and everybody
along with you
a lesson i never forgot and implied it
in the next
four eras five years each never looked
back again
but that is the seduction of a public
ownership
you know it was hard to put a a a
a wise head on a 30 year old body that
had enjoyed an immense amount of success
it was a real problem uh i got fired
um had to talk my way back in we had
realized the error of our ways
and i said give me another quarter and
the board luckily did
and but we had to learn a lesson it was
a tough tough lesson
a tough five years yeah what's so
interesting
is uh now after having done you know for
35 years and kind of had the uh the
benefit of hindsight uh
you're very rational about you know
being a 30 year old who had a bunch of
success and
you know as a 32 year old you always
kind of remind yourself like yeah i
probably am
uh acting arrogant compared to my future
self
right i will look back and vic i knew
nothing um
talk through a little bit like what did
you do in the moment
uh to try to surround yourself with
maybe um
people who were older or who had more
experience or
uh could kind of help you understand the
things that you didn't know were there
specific things you did
or was it literally just trial by fire
and i'm gonna show up to work every day
and i gotta figure this out
uh you know one way or the other
it goes back a little bit to what i was
saying sometimes when you're in the
midst of a problem
when you read and you get counsel and go
to seminars
the nugget or the issue that you're
wrestling with might come to you
i remember vividly sitting in
my wing chair in my living room reading
david alberstam's
best and brightest which was his review
of the kennedy and johnson
administration's
administration of the vietnamese war and
what he maintained
in his book was although the
administration was comprised of the best
and brightest most well-educated
people that that our country had to
provide
uh they were basically basing their
numbers on
far reports body counts never going into
the hamlets in the villages where the
war was being waged
to really find out what was going to
happen they suffered from what alberstam
called hubris
arrogance and i sat in that chair and
said oh my god
he could just as well be talking about
me
and we convened talked about it
began to set up processes planning
processes
uh reinvigorated our board made sure
that there were people wise heads that
were able to
to be able to test whether or not i had
mission creep
whether my objectives were appropriate
or not a better trial
a better group of people to be able to
to to manage
major strategic decisions so it occurred
as a result of a lightning strike
from a book but then we began to set
processes
and policies in place to ensure that we
didn't do that again
in fact when we sat down and we
discussed it as a management team
we decided that each of us would go into
the field and each year visit 100
locations
talk directly to franchise owners travel
with district managers
get a feel we also decided we would work
one day
waiting on customers in the store so
that we would have not only the you know
the notion of being responsible for
strategy and organization
communication all the things that senior
managers do
but we make sure that we were in touch
with frontline frontline people who
really ran the business on a daily basis
and we created an advisory council
of elected representatives to meet with
us where we had
clear objectives that guided us like
store profitability growth
that would ensure that we would
continually improve the system
and that people got buy-in and it was
wonderful we we went and apologized for
the oversights of a bad strategy before
we took full responsibility not 50 50
100
zero you know wouldn't blame leadership
if problems occurred take full
responsibility wouldn't
blame the team my teammates if the
problems occurred leadership would take
100 responsibility
so you know a lot of learning comes from
making mistakes
and and that was the case in my my
talking personally about myself
that was a clear learning point for me
absolutely when i hear you talk
uh and understand that you were in the
military uh
a lot of what you're talking about is
leadership lessons that were also taught
in the military how important do you
think it was
that experience and kind of preparing
you to uh to run a business
and kind of have the success that you
did
partly uh it became a lot of different
influences
i was an enlisted man but in those days
when you took
basic training i was begging as a squad
leader and then advanced individual
training i was a platoon leader
so i was responsible for my men getting
ready for card duty and kp
getting them to class on time uh
ensuring that they were there when they
were asking for extra leave on weekends
with the captain of the company so so it
it helped me understand the importance
of taking care of my team
um i think other lessons really can't a
lot of my lessons in terms of what what
a ceo does
actually came out of business school my
second year business school
we took strategy courses that was how i
got the instinct about
what i saw was a faulty strategy that
existed in the business
it was far too much experimentation and
not enough exploitation of the
diamond and the rough that they had
within their midst so that was a
a lot a lot of help came in so and it
came from all different sources i
you know basically as i look back it
really was
a lot of different things that helped me
and mostly
if i had to say what was the most
important element of it
was what i learned from my colleagues i
had exceptional teammates
and and uh there's a
a book that really touched me uh by
michael eisner of all people who
talked about working together and the
beauty of if you look behind you
lift the curtain of most enterprises and
in life too in families
you won't find one person on a white
horse that comes in and saves the day
what you generally find is a couple of
people at least who love each other
respect each other
are not vying and competitive with each
other that are there to support and
complement each other
and that was the case with our team and
i had a team partner a guy by the name
of tom schwartz for 20 years
who is my almost my you know we weren't
fit legally business partners
but my ceo would come up through the
ranks the guy would graduate business
school year after me
who was essential i i the business
wouldn't have been the same business
without it
and i think if you pull the curtain
behind a lot of institutions a lot of
families and a lot of a lot of
businesses you'll generally find that
symbiotic relationship exists
and elsewhere so i learned a lot from my
teammates
they really were like exceptional group
of people we were together for a long
time
and i owe them a great deal yeah that's
amazing
um one of the things that you guys did
very very well was you kind of continued
to
reinvent uh what was on the menu and
kind of innovate
and keep pushing forward in terms of the
offerings that you had
uh there's things like the munchkins or
the culadas and all kind of all this
stuff
talk a little bit about just what was
the process internally how intentional
is it versus kind of serendipitous
uh in terms of creating these new
products and really
scaling them to a national organization
so that you can
remain fresh and kind of at the top of
mind for consumers
early on it was serendipitous the
introduction of jumbo java which moving
from a six ounce to go cup of coffee to
a 10 ounce cup of coffee
came from a competitor uh or a marketing
head i hired from a competitor
munchkins was an idea that surfaced from
our hartford franchise on this
a lady by the name of edna demery the
wife of our franchise owner bob demary
she created munchkins but later on it
became very sophisticated and very
process oriented
basically we had a first-rate marketing
department
we had product managers for bakery
beverage
and donut categories their job was to
continually
search the marketplace the competition
the consumer
we took ideas every which way we ballot
tested them
we tested them thoroughly a year in
advance in order to ensure that they
delivered on the
same store sales growth that we wanted
we tried news is important in a retail
business
whether it be price product promotion
there always should be some activity
that excites and enthralls the consumer
given another reason
to come into the store and so we manage
those calendars very carefully
and product was among them and and in
terms of business strategy
we used a planning model it's now pretty
much commonplace when we started
we modeled our performance way back when
we first ran into trouble
so in the early 70s we were using jay
forester's concept of modeling
and we wanted to grow earnings at at
least 15 percent that stroke
that drove us to keep innovating and
adjusting
and need to plant saplings well in
advance
of the time that you might need those
earnings and those that worked out well
you know we'd water them and make sure
that they grew and those that didn't
work out so well we'd stop
so there would be a lot of a lot of
false starts
you got to sort of put a lot to catch
fish you got to put a lot of hooks in
the water
sometimes so we did we did a lot of uh
measured experimentation still achieving
our objective but with an eye to the
future
both in terms of markets and in terms of
products and in terms of business
strategy
absolutely you also uh in multiple
other organizations you were involved in
either as the operator or
on the board they've built very
recognizable defendable brands
and so obviously there's some value to
that
talk about how important that was how
intentional the brand building
and kind of how you saw that as an asset
as you built these businesses
i think brand is hugely important to me
a brand is a shorthand for the
goods and services on offer and
for the consumer it basically is a time
saver
their most precious asset is time
and it allows someone when you have a
well-identified
brand that consistently delivers it
shorthands and saves the consumer
time that is a valuable benefit to the
consumer
and so for example when we were building
our chain out
we did not go where we got an interest
from a prospective franchisee to grow in
china and wyoming
we were very intentional in terms of
building distribution in a market
to build brand we weren't so aware of
its value until we actually
bought the mr donut chain and rebadged
it then we were
among very few who are in a position to
really measure
brands so in new england where the
duncan brand was much stronger than the
mr brand
same store same operator a minor
remodeling a change from the mr sign
to the duncan sign sales went up 40
let me repeat that 40 value of a brand
in markets where we had similar
distribution some places in pennsylvania
sales went up 12 in those markets where
duncan had no presence
no history no brand recognition and mr
had something like toronto they had 10
or 15 stores
we had none when we re-badged one in the
first and second so
sales went down 10 so i could say in our
case
if you want to know what the value of a
brand was in those days if the
average sales of the store was were five
or six hundred thousand dollars and now
close to a million but but maybe even
more um but but
you know a value of a brand can be worth
hundreds of thousands of dollars to a
store
and what's interesting about that is um
why do you why do you think that is it
because there's a trust with the brand
and especially in kind of the food
services uh retail chain business
they kind of know what they're going to
get when they walk in and so there's
this promise of consistency and
and kind of value or is it something
else as to why the brand was so powerful
when you would go into markets
trust is important in every real
relationship it's essential
and no successful relationship exists
without trust and if you look behind it
when you don't have trust
it's rare you can ever have any kind of
success and so
you know trust is the ability basically
in my in my view
of four things it's it's sincerity your
public and private conversation the same
competence you basically can live up to
the standards that you set up
uh reliability as you meet your promises
and finally is care
so i think the answer to your question
is people have trust and
the fast food business qsr business
quick service restaurant business
uh runs on two things always has it
seems to continue to this day
and it really runs on value and
convenience and value is more than price
value is a whole series of attributes
one of which
is trust i think i place a high value on
trust
absolutely yeah reliability is one
element
that builds that trust for sure and so
you
built an amazing team you built an
amazing business
one of the challenges of running the
type of business that you did versus
many of the people who listen to this
who run kind of digitally first
businesses
is that you're trying to build a culture
and trying to build an employee base
that is all kind of rowing in the same
direction
but they're literally scattered among
hundreds if not thousands of locations
across the country
and so how did you think about culture
and morale
and kind of really ensuring that
everyone was working towards the same
goals even though they may not be in the
same office
or even know who each other are kind of
the national service worker level
well part of it was the planning process
everybody was involved
and we had everybody had a clear view of
what our purpose was
what our mission what our objectives
were uh what the strategic four or five
strategic levels we were going to pull
in any
one year to bridge scarce resources the
achievement of those objectives
and then the tactics that supported that
and we used that common planning
language throughout even
for franchisees and district meetings we
would we would
have them uh utilize that same language
and that same framework
to keep aligned and keep together uh we
had a lot of high-touch
uh supplemental services to what would
be a hierarchical
organizational form you know in our
business we have thousands of operations
far flowing all over the place
people expect consistency and sort of
delivery but there had to be an
informal network that supported that
which was high touch
and that was store visits that was
advisory council meetings
that was fun outings
constant contact in terms of ensuring
that everybody
sort of was subscribing and aligned
communication became extremely important
and every one of these
methods of processes was designed in
order to accomplish that
but a lot of it in my view starts with
really having consistent planning
language
and engaging everybody in it and
utilizing it year in and year out
i find in a lot of cases where people
aren't clear about defining terms it can
be an awful lot of misery
and unhappiness and morale we would take
temperature meetings we basically had
staff
every couple of years we do an attitude
usage study which we do with consumers
we would do them with our staff to find
out a big question i would always
look to in that and other businesses
right served on the boards
is would you recommend this as a place
to come to work to your friends and
family
that was a big touch for me that people
really loved it and really would
recommend it to others to come
join us we knew then that our
communication policies our pay policies
that the mood the teamwork that we were
trying to engender the culture we were
trying to incent
was on track when it was off that was
like a red that's a
a red alarm fire for us in terms of
finding out
why what went wrong and how to fix it
yeah
one of the keys to building a national
brand and business like you did
was uh obviously making investments and
kind of thinking about where you're
going to
focus your time resources and energy how
did you
think about kind of evaluating all the
different options that you had and then
kind of prioritizing where to make
investment and where maybe to
um you know kind of wait till later to
actually make those investments was
there any process or framework that you
use
to uh to make sure the first thing we
would you know we really wanted to
maintain a
uh a real significant competitive
advantage
with the consumer day in and day out i
mean if you're gonna be in a business
doesn't have a huge menu
you're only in certain day parts and
you're competing against
other businesses that are in more more
day parts you've got to make sure that
that the offering and it really does
provide a
sustainable competitive advantage so
first investments generally went to
ensure the product quality delivered on
what it promised to be uh and after that
it was
pretty standard stuff i would say the
things that competed so long as they
were within
the mission were basically whether or
not i would provide it
at the store level something on the
order of at least a 15
roi before we would ask a franchise
owner to be able to invest in it
it had to be worth it while they would
stop following us
if in fact we asked them to remodel a
store
which is an important thing to provide a
new face every seven to ten years pretty
standard
in the industry but if we couldn't
justify that on an roi basis to them we
would not do it
we would not ask them to make that this
that investment
because we believe to us to our very
core
that if we allow them to make too many
bad investments
that they would stop following us that
they wouldn't listen in the future
and so we would search around until we
found
the right combination of factors in our
case we found out
the gaining variable for that was that
if there were more than four people
online there was a 25
block rate in terms of customers turning
away one out of four would lead
so we found out that we had to have more
throughput in terms of more registers
and more touch points with customers
the point being is is that we ensured
that we had to have a minimum
roi for the for our franchisees
and and that's where most of the
investments were made they were made
mostly at the store level
mostly made by independent businessmen
the franchisees themselves
in terms of our our major investments
the
the one investment i did make along in
the 35 years
was when we diversified in the last era
of the company's existence or next to
the last year of the companies
my administration was basically in
chile's restaurants
and there we had found that same store
sales were slipping
and the fast food area as the baby
boomers were aging
and they were moving to to casual dining
operations and we took a license for
chili's and we began to invest some
money in chili's hopefully to plant
those saplings for future growth as it
turned out uh
events worked out so i had to sell that
business and so never really was able to
keep it to fruition but that was the one
diversification that we did make the
required capital other than that
most of the investments were being made
on behalf of franchisees that's one of
the advantages of a franchise system to
the franchisor
once you get a brand going and you build
that you basically
can invite other people in to invest
wisely and
to grow the business yeah it's
absolutely fascinating
and how did you think about
incentivizing the franchisees right so
obviously there's a
number of different models that people
use when franchising
but how did you think about balancing uh
the financial incentive and kind of
feeling of ownership for franchisee but
also ensuring that
um the duncan brand and kind of core
business
had uh significant upside and also
control over that kind of brand quality
like
where was that balance found basically
it started
with one of the three objectives that
the company had
and talk about mission objectives
objective uh
mission is what you want to be and
objectives of what you want to have in
our case it was a 15
compound rate of growth the second
objective we had as a company
was to ensure at least a 15 roi at the
unit level for the franchisee
that drove us so that we were ensuring
that
they would have a fair return for the
amount of effort and time
that they put into the franchise when i
traveled to the stores i would often ask
the franchisees
one of the two questions i would ask
them is if you had to do this all over
again
would you invest again because that was
to me a question that really
was the acid test or whether we were
delivering on our promise
second question i always ask them so if
you were the ceo of the company today
what would you do differently
than we're currently doing so those are
my two standard questions
but we would we were driven by by that
that return
and we were and today
less understood that a franchisee
is in business for himself but not by
himself
he has the advantage having a large
company and when we changed the way we
went to market
uh away from manufacturing product in
each and every store
to sometimes doing that and more often
moving out of commissaries
and unless space and broad distribution
began a franchise not a store
but a territory the rois went up
dramatically as did the rate of growth
growth so
dunkin donut franchisees initially
started his mom and pop operations
provided a wonderful stand of living and
improving the standard of living
to hundreds of families that wouldn't
have existed without us
as we changed the business over time it
became a lot more than that now there
are
enterprises or franchisees that run into
the hundreds of stores
and and net worths that are in the tens
of millions of dollars
as franchisees most people don't realize
the tremendous wealth potential
that a franchise can offer when people
consider entrepreneurship
this is something they should really
give give a look at
today in a lot of communities the
pillars of those communities
are it could be automobile dealers john
deere dealerships
dunkin donuts franchise owners in in a
community
uh it's amazing what from little acorns
these wonderful oaks have grown
and so we were very mindful
of that kind of opportunity and
everything that we kept doing
was designed not only to thrill the
customer but also to ensure that that
franchisee who was delivering day in and
day out
was the backbone of the business was
getting a fair return and an opportunity
to really build an enterprise empire
absolutely
that's fantastic um i highly suggest
everyone go get this book uh it is
called around the corner
to around the world a dozen lessons i
learned running
dunkin donuts robert you are uh
fantastic and a wealth of knowledge uh
before i let you go i ask everybody the
same two questions and then you'll get
to ask me one
to finish up the first one is what is
the most important
book that you ever read in your career
well i would go back and say
halberstam's book because of the
the influence it had on me and and it's
a lesson
and never learned you need humility you
got to stay open and you got to stay
but there's so many i mean and and and
and the appendix to my book i think i
list
you know 20 books that maybe have made
an impact and
and influenced me uh chris is a guy
that's a partner i think
at bain wrote expand from the core
uh really about don't don't
don't change your mission too quickly be
very thoughtful about it
but there are there are a number of of
terrific books
all of which i've listed uh in the back
of the book
that have influenced me that i've found
useful over time
awesome the second question is a new one
for listeners i used to ask people if
they believed in aliens and i got tired
of hearing everyone tell me yes
so uh i'm gonna try a new one which is
uh who is your
business hero who's somebody that you
look up to and think
you know that you tried to emulate
throughout your career
the guy that i look at mostly now i
think is bill gates
uh i i'm impressed by
his thinking his values his character
what he and his wife melinda have done
together as a team
in terms of helping society and helping
mankind
i i think yeah i think i aspired to some
of the
things that i see him as a both as a as
a bright young businessman did
i i admire this generation of
tech leadership they are so much more
sophisticated and on target and
that i was at 30. uh i i admire
a lot of them but uh but of all of them
i think it was now middle age
but i think bill gates probably is one
of the better models for people to
follow
he uh you can't go wrong with picking
him for that answer for sure
uh you could ask me one question to uh
to end this what uh what one question do
you have for me
what part of this resonated with you
which
which which the topic i noticed that you
were making notes when we were talking
about organization
which part most resonated with you what
did you take away from this
this conversation i tend to think that
um it's the simplest piece of advice
because everyone knows that it's
true but it's very easy to forget um
it's actually about leadership
it's just the person who is the leader
in every organization there might be
many people involved that you know
they're all kind of working as a team
but ultimately there is one person who
is going to take responsibility
uh when things go wrong and then
hopefully shower all of the you know the
praise on everyone else when things go
right
whoever that person is you go the way of
the leader
right and i think that people uh
easily forget that because there's so
much complexity in business and
things can get much more um kind of
nuanced but at the end of the day if you
have uh
good leadership then you can usually
figure out the problems and then figure
out a way to thrive
you got that right you take the pain
when things go wrong share the rewards
and the glory when things go right
absolutely sir
listen thank you so much for doing this
was fantastic i think people are really
gonna love it
thanks bob thank you very much